today we are checking out the microsoft
surface duo
[Music]
and yes we are turning the screen on
today
this device has been so much fun to use
over the past few weeks and i'm so
excited to finally get a chance to show
it to you but first
let's dive into the specs starting price
is 13.99 with storage options of 128 and
256 gigs
qualcomm snapdragon 855 processor 6 gigs
of ram
it has a single 11 megapixel camera
capable of capturing 4k video it also
has a flash
usbc charging fingerprint sensor dual
batteries giving you a total of 3577
milliamps
usbc charging with video output
capabilities have this set as a
displayport in to usbc
and guess what it's working the screens
are what this device is mostly about
it has dual 5.6 inch oled displays that
each work separately to run both android
and microsoft 365 apps
and it weighs about 250 grams it's super
thin
at 4.8 millimeters and
9.6 millimeters when it's folded the
front and back are both corning gorilla
glass making it
have a really super smooth feel
especially with the lack of a camera
bump
it's seamless it also has a mono speaker
and a dual mic with noise suppression
and echo cancellation this will help out
with
all those microsoft teams calls the 360
degree hinge
is what gives this device so many
different options and possibilities of
use they like to call these
postures the one that i found myself
using the most was book mode
there's also dual landscape single
screen tent mode
compose and peak mode so things that
really
set this apart from some of the other
foldable devices on the market while yes
this is foldable it's running two
screens separately allowing for
multitasking having optimized windows
apps is a huge plus because they're able
to develop and take full advantage of
all of those new postures and different
modes
and make it work very seamless with
every app in every
posture it's also really easy to link
your phone to windows on your computer
you could do this before on some samsung
devices
but they've made it even easier now with
a duo you'll be able to use the your
phone app to sync photos videos and
messages
obviously this is something that we're
all very used to in the mac ecosystem so
being able to do this easily
using the your phone app on windows i'm
a fan so let's remember
this is a first gen device so there are
some things that this is lacking
i feel like this was something that
microsoft was hoping that they would
have had released
a little bit earlier than they are now
there's no wireless charging
there's no 5g it does have an older
qualcomm snapdragon 855 processor many
people were questioning why microsoft
didn't use the latest snapdragon
processor and that's because qualcomm
requires the device to include a
separate 5g chip
to use the 865. sadly when the surface
duo was finalized
there wasn't any room to install a 5g
chip thus
the 855. now i'd imagine on the next
version they would have a longer battery
but what they've done
in such a slim form factor is pretty
impressive
i haven't really noticed the battery
life being too terrible they do have it
rated to get up to 15 and a half hours
of local video playback 10 hours of
standby time
and 27 hours of talk time and
i hope i never have to talk to anybody
i do always hate talking about things
that i don't like especially about
devices that i love
so let's focus on the things that are
really incredible about this the pluses
on this thing really do
outweigh some of the negatives and this
is something that i found myself using
so much more for emails doing work
browsing the web and even hanging out on
twitter and instagram at the same time
because that's what everybody needs
at a time like this so for content
creation i have found myself going back
to my iphone just to take photos or
videos but this is such a slim and small
device that i've been taking this with
me
in addition to my iphone and yes it does
fit in my yoga pants
so all is well on that front something
that i found myself using this a lot for
is email
and even on my iphone like this is how i
type like i normally will open up
something
and like this is how i type and everyone
thinks it's super weird so what's great
about this
is i can do my super weird typing but
actually have dual screens
so my keyboard will be on the bottom and
my email or whatever it is that i'm
working on is at the top
that's called compose mode so let's get
composing
not only does it have a keyboard that
you can type like this or like this
you can make the keyboard different
sizes depending upon how you are holding
this which is cool because you can type
one-handed it also has slide to type
which
i've found myself using that so much
more since the latest version of ios
started integrating that into their
keyboards so now i've gotten so
used to the swipe to type i'm not sure
if any of you guys use that but once you
kind of master it
it's pretty great and super quick this
is something that you didn't even know
that you would need
to be able to look at instagram and
twitter
at the same time like i could be
scrolling like this is this is not
healthy but i love it
i could be looking at instagrams i could
be composing my tweets
what other app groups would be fun
disney plus
and netflix like netflix
and imdb oh yeah i guess or
yeah but like what if i want to watch
disney plus and netflix at the same time
okay watch this is cool
you just click on it you do groups and
then you pick whichever other app you
want so i'm going to pick the disney
plus we now have an app group so when
you click on this app group it will open
both of them
at the same time on the screen microsoft
had some
app groups already set up here like the
plan
so this is convenient you'll have your
email pop-up on one side
and your to-do list pop-up on the other
side yeah but have you had netflix and
disney plus
open to say oh my gosh what about
postmates and grubhub it's like
this is great postmates and my fitness
pal
so you get really comfortable using two
screens and when you get so used to that
when i go back to my iphone
it's kind of weird because i can't do
the things that i was used to doing on
here so quickly because you do have
these two screens and you just kind of
feel yourself
going through these different postures
so if i'm
on instagram and twitter i can be
scrolling and then i decide oh hold on a
second i want to make this full screen
so i just kind of fold it like this do
my scrolling
see what everyone's up to so instagram
probably isn't the best demo to show you
guys but the fact that you can do this
and it still looks really neat
i'm into it so if i'm scrolling and i
decide let's go into single screen mode
i just fold it back and it will
automatically
switch back to single mode so you can
just continue to scroll
something that you'll notice is this
dynamic taskbar so this will move
around depending upon if you have
different apps open so if i'm going to
open up my messages
that will slide over to the other screen
and you'll still be able to have access
to all of those
just as you would if they were on both
screens so here's my messages
she's got a lot of friends that have
been chatting with me i have jenna
and tyler and then jenna again watching
youtube is really cool
i've been watching this girl named
sophie lloyd she does really cool guitar
covers and now
basically all of her videos have been
recommended to me all the time
there's a bon jovi shred version yes and
her guitar is
purple
[Music]
so we've got the video up here and you
can scroll you can read comments
i wonder if she needs a drummer i'm not
one yet but i'm just saying like in the
future
in the future i'm here even if you're
looking at it like this yes there's a
crease down the middle but
you can still view the comments on the
side so the speaker's right here on the
top
it is only on one side which i mean it's
not that big of a deal but i do feel
like in a future version it will be
really cool if they do have stereo
speakers but that is gonna
be interesting to try to figure out how
that's gonna work with all the different
postures
because you will want it to be stereo no
matter which way i feel like that's
going to pose a challenge
like i mentioned before book mode is
kind of the mode that i feel like i use
the most because this does give you
easy access to both sides of the screens
you can go into full screen mode very
easily and then you can quickly switch
to the single screen mode and it's cool
because every time you do this
everything adapts to your actions so as
you can see this is now
on the front whereas the back is turned
off and if i want to switch it
it sensed that i flipped the screen over
it is giving you that option that now oh
guess what it thinks
that i want to switch it now this motion
is kind of interesting because this also
will carry over into the camera and
this is super cool this only has one
camera so a lot of people were saying
but it doesn't have
a front facing camera doesn't have a
back facing camera it has one camera and
those can both be
the same thing watch me now so right now
i have a selfie camera
and it will automatically switch to the
back camera and flip the screen so now
the camera is obviously on the back and
the screen switched
to the front screen so that i'd be able
to see what it's taking a picture of so
let's take a picture of
this mess over here and now we're going
to flip it
and now it's flipped to the front facing
so you can do slow mo
240 120 you can also do regular video
you can shoot 1080 30 1080 60 4k 30 and
4k
60. there's portrait mode and panorama i
just got a notification from starbucks
that tomorrow is double star day
i lost all my stars because i haven't
gone to starbucks in like six months i
mean
what is this i'm gonna get my free
birthday drink
maybe let's go out and test out some
photos and videos so you guys can see
what this looks like oh this man this
background looks so good
so i know this isn't technically a phone
it's sort of a phone but guess what you
can make phone calls on it
obviously because it has a sim card so
it does have data and i'm going to call
jenna right now because i want to order
some food
so i'm going to call her to see if
that's something that she's into
let's use that speaker wonder if she's
gonna answer
this is really disheartening i'm
receiving a phone call from jenna
[Music]
hello hello
this is cool i can send you a call a
video call
oh hi
i see your camera are you making a video
too
i'm telling you that's cool do you want
some food but here's the real question
do you need to pick up food do you want
it do you want to um do
do you think like maybe you want to like
let me know what food you want
if you click the three dots you can go
so it's getting dark i was going to take
some photos out here so i only got a
chance to take a little bit but
uh food do i talk about food
how about this i'll go i will go pick up
food
i could buy cool wait you didn't tell me
what you wanted text me it okay great
she hung up
does she not understand that i'm hungry
[Music]
once upon a time there was a little
doggie named maddie smell that
learn about it
[Music]
i took a few photos on the iphone and
the surface duo just so you guys can get
a comparison to see what each one looks
like
these first ones are in portrait mode so
you can tell that the duo
actually did a pretty good job around my
hair the iphone obviously is pretty good
most of the time with portrait mode
look at me having a very nice sick
portrait mode of me sitting on the bench
in the duo
it basically blurred out everything
except
for the top part of my body this is
non-portrait mode so you can tell that
everything sort of is in focus i do feel
like i
don't think that i look very crisp it's
definitely a softer image so when you
zoom into the iphone
you can see that the photos are way more
sharp this is kind of a cool shot i
didn't take one on the iphone so i don't
have one to compare but i was facing
this light strip and there was a lot of
light so it kind of helped illuminate my
face a little
you can tell there is a lot more
smoothing going on
on the duo the iphone still is much
sharper i mean the photos are good
you're still able to take photos you'll
be able to capture things that are
happening around you just not at the
high quality
that the iphone or other premium
smartphones
[Music]
this is a video test i would say it's
front facing but it's the same camera
so it technically is front facing right
now but when i flip it around
it'll then be back facing
back facing back facing taking maddie
for a walk
maddie do you miss jenna your friend
jenna do you know that jenna loves you
and mommy thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this will also work with the surface
pens which is kind of exciting this is
one of the slim versions the back is
also a little bit magnetic so you can
even
keep your surface pen right there on the
back i don't think this was planned i
think it's just this is magnetic so that
they'll stay closed
but a nice little added bonus
that's a hat let's add a little
highlighter back here in the green
this is pure talent it is kind of cool
that this will work on here that is
something that i hope
that apple finally will let us do on the
next version of the iphone can we please
use the apple pencil
on the iphone simple request and we also
have a fingerprint scanner
[Music]
xcloud gaming is finally here so you're
able to play xbox game pass
games on your mobile devices and it's
exciting because it also launched for
samsung which i did show you guys a
little demo of that in the z
fold but now we're going to be playing
it here on the duo
we're about the peli sim halo it's
loading up right now
and it's really hard to play a first
person shooter game in such a small
screen like this if you're
trying to have a really good kd this is
probably not the route that you want to
go but there's so many other games that
are probably better suited for this type
of gameplay but the fact that i am
connecting my xbox controller
is so cool i also can
can you see it okay this is neat it
looks actually really good
i mean you can tell the bezels you can
see them pretty prominently on the
screen
the fact that i'm playing halo on here
still is shocking
this area is clear is it because i
am getting shot so you're a liar i'm not
saying that this is the best way to play
halo
but i am showing you that yeah it does
work
[Music]
most of the complaints that i do have
after using this feels like they're all
things that can be addressed with
software updates the hardware feels very
premium carrying this thing around
just feels really comfortable and
natural there were some times that the
camera snapped photos a little slow
there is some lagging with scrolling and
some of the third-party apps weren't
behaving correctly when you're switching
quickly between different modes but i
feel like again those are all things
that once this device is actually out
they'll be able to address those very
easily
now my sister brought up this really
great point when i was yelling at her
for not answering my team's call
[Music]
she's gonna get it hello
it was because she didn't even see the
call hey so what's going on what are you
doing you working on your video
i've just been editing all day i took a
break and i went for a walk oh that's
nice it's weird out
the weather's weird so i was like i want
to go back inside so now back inside
back in my computer cool well we did
that i'm chatting with jenna
i do feel like this needs something on
the front to be able to tell if you have
some notifications because if not you
have to make sure that it's opened up
i'm not saying the entire front screen
has to be like the new z-fold but
the front of this display is pretty
awesome but having this front cover
display like this
does add to the thickness i'm not saying
that this is the answer
so maybe something a little more like
the z-flip with this you're able to see
if you have notifications you can tell
the time
i think this would probably be the best
option all in all
i think that this has a really great
future this is the first
generation i don't think that this is
perfect by any means there's so many
things that they will need to do to make
this better before
first gen i'm pretty excited about what
the future of this surface duo can be
let me know if you guys have any
questions about this or anything that i
talked about in this video leave them in
the comments below and i will see you in
my next video but don't forget to
subscribe and hit the bell so you'll be
notified
when i do post another video
we're gonna have a haircut it's on the
23rd
so i was thinking that if your haircut
was on the 23rd
we could squeeze in like a dog park
visit
the dog park
after a walk maybe i know those are all
your favorite things